welcome back to the white house
i'm honored to welcome prime minister
lee to the white house today
and i'm proud and i mean sincerely i'm
really proud of the partnership
that
between singapore and the united states
it's as close and as strong as it's ever
been
and together we're working to uphold a
rules-based order international order
supporting the founding principles of
the united nations
and advance a future for the
indo-pacific that is both free and open
as we look toward the future
prime minister lee and i
share a commitment to asean as
and its centrality and all of what we do
and i'm looking forward to hosting the
asean leaders here in washington d.c
for a special summit this spring
we also discussed a wide range of
concerns
for peace and stability in the
indo-pacific
that includes ensuring that all nations
in the region including china
uphold the principles that enable a free
and open region
singapore and the united states are both
committed to freedom of navigation
as well as unimpeded flow of maritime
commerce in the south china sea
we shared our concerns about the
democratic people's republic of korea
and their destabilizing ballistic
missile launches
and then clear by which are clearly in
violation of multiple u.n council
resolutions security council resolutions
and we both urge north korea to refrain
from further provocations and return to
the negotiation table for serious and
sustained diplomacy
we're deeply concerned both of us by
the continuing suffering and violence in
burma following last year's military
coup
the coup had caused humanitarian crisis
and
reversed a decade of democratic and
economic progress for the people of
burma
singapore and the united states agree
that the military regime must urgently
implement the asean five-point consensus
and return
burma to its path to democratic
transition
and we also discussed the war in ukraine
last week in europe
the world saw the strong unity for
unified response and resolve among the
nato alliance
the g7 and the european union to answer
putin's brutal and unjustified assault
on ukraine
today with the prime minister's visit
and singapore's strong leadership on
this issue
it's clear that the putin's war
and unacceptable nations in every region
in the world not just europe and in
every region of the world
it's an attack on the core international
principles and it that underpin peace
and security and prosperity everywhere
including in the indo-pacific today
singapore and the united states are
united
and sending the message to all nations
to all nations regardless of their size
or population
they are equal in their right and their
rights on the global stage they have a
right to sovereignty and territorial
integrity and to determine their own
future free from violence and
intimidation
mr prime minister
our nations cooperate closely on
security and counterterrorism we have
for some time
and we have deep commercial and economic
ties we've also developed deep personal
ties as well i must acknowledge
and i we're going to continue to deepen
our partnership
and seize the opportunities to meet the
challenges of the moment and to meet
them together
fighting cover 19 making sure we're
prepared for the next pandemic
increasing our climate ambitions and
working to decarbonize the shipping
sector
cooperating everything from cyber
security to space exploration
promoting a broad-based economic growth
throughout the indo-pacific including by
working together to develop an
indo-pacific economic framework that
will drive enduring prosperity across
the region
so we have a large agenda mr prime
minister an important agenda a shared
vision that we are jointly pursuing a
free and open indo-pacific and
indo-pacific that is connected
prosperous and more secure and more
resilient
and the u.s singapore partnership is
essential i believe to realize that
future
so thank you again prime minister lee
i always appreciate consulting with you
and as i told you
both you and singapore
punch way above your weight
way above your weight and i value the
time we spend together and look forward
to many more meetings
the floor is yours
thank you president biden thank you for
those warm remarks
president biden ladies and gentlemen
i'd like to thank the president for the
very warm welcome that i and my
delegation have received
we last met in rome on the sidelines of
the g20 summit
but
much has changed since
those few months ago
current international uncertainties and
crisis underscore the need
for countries to work together with
close friends and partners
and singapore deeply appreciates the
america's commitment to engage southeast
asia and especially singapore
despite the ongoing crisis in ukraine
we had a very good discussion with
president biden this morning
we reaffirmed the long-standing and
multifaceted partnership between
singapore and the us
and our shared commitment to a stable
rules-based global order
the u.s has played an important and
constructive role in the asia pacific
for more than for nearly 80 years
and singapore has consistently supported
a strong u.s presence in the region
through our words and actions
we have substantial bilateral
cooperation on economic defence and
security issues and also strong
people-to-people ties
singapore is the second largest asian
investor in the us
and the u.s is the largest investor in
singapore
singapore's investments in the us
and u.s exports to singapore support
over a quarter million american jobs
on the defense front singapore is a
major security cooperation partner of
the u.s in fact the only country with
this
status
for more than 30 years
we've had an mou on defense cooperation
signed in 1990 and recently renewed in
2019
which has provided the u.s military
access to singapore's air and naval
bases
we are also expanding our cooperation
into new areas including cyber security
digital economy sustainable development
and even space
singapore deeply appreciates president
biden's leadership in strengthening u.s
engagement in the region
we welcome his intention to host an
asean u.s special summit here soon
it's a strong affirmation of american
commitment to southeast asia and to
asean centrality
the president and i discussed the
importance of the us growing both its
strategic and economic stakes
in the asia pacific
it's important to advance a positive
economic agenda that's open inclusive
up-to-date and flexible
we therefore welcome america's proposed
indo-pacific economic framework
which will strengthen america's
engagement in the evolving regional
economic architecture
i discussed with the president his
recent visit to europe and the ongoing
crisis in ukraine
singapore is a staunch supporter of
international law and the u.n charter
which prohibits acts of aggression
against a sovereign state
and that's why we've strongly condemned
the unprovoked attack by russia
on ukraine
the sovereignty political independence
and territorial integrity of all
countries big and small must be
respected
the unprovoked military invasion of a
sovereign country under any pretext
is unacceptable
we cannot condone any country arguing
that another country's independence
is the result of historical errors
and crazy decisions
i shared with president biden the
measures that singapore has taken to
constrain russia's capacity
to conduct war against ukraine
our actions are based on principles that
are fundamental to our survival and
existence as an independent sovereign
nation
we've upheld these principles and voted
in accordance with them at the u.n in
successive crisis over many decades
involving
different countries
the war in the ukraine has implications
for the asia pacific
there are potential flash points and
contentious issues in our region too
which if not managed well
could escalate to open conflict
countries with interests in the region
need to pursue all efforts to settle
disagreements through peaceful means so
that we can avoid reaching a point of no
return
it's important therefore to keep open
channels of dialogue between countries
including at the highest level
this will help to manage developments
in order to avoid conflict and prevent
misreading each other's intentions
we also need to create inclusive
constructs to bridge differences and
encourage cooperation and
interdependence in the asia pacific
for example the apec leaders meeting
and the proposed indo-pacific economic
framework
the u.s has enduring strategic interests
in the asia pacific
and many friends in the region who want
you to stay actively and consistently
engaged
and i'm confident that within this
regional context singapore's own
relationship with the u.s will continue
to grow from strength to strength thank
you very much thank you
now we each agreed we take one question
and
uh i'll as i'll recognize someone first
darlene superville associated press
thank you mr president
what is your view of russia's
announcement today that it will quote
fundamentally scale back its military
operations
near kiev and another northern city in
ukraine do you see this as
uh possibly the war beginning to come to
an end or do you see this as russia
trying to buy time and to recalibrate
for
a new military effort
we'll see i don't read anything into it
until i see what their actions are
we'll see if they follow through on what
they're suggesting
there are negotiations that have begun
today or not begun continued today one
in turkey and others i
had a meeting with the heads of state of
our four
allies in nato
france germany uh
the united states and uh and
uh and great britain
and uh there seems to be a consensus
that uh
let's just see what they have to offer
we'll find out what they do but in the
meantime
we're going to continue to keep strong
the sanctions we're going to continue to
provide
the ukrainian military with their
capacity to defend themselves and we're
going to continue to keep a close eye on
what's going on
good afternoon mr president and good
afternoon
uh prime minister
uh prime minister you've advocated
the benefits for the united states to
develop a bipartisan consensus on asia
that asia depends upon a predictable u.s
policy towards the region how assured
are you though
that the momentum that you've seen
with asean u.s engagement has the
ability to move the needle on shared
objectives in the asia pacific towards
the fundamentals that we all
need to live by
peace prosperity and economic
development and basically how well is
president biden doing in this regard
i think if you put it at a very broad
level there is consensus in the united
states on
the direction of their policy in the
asia pacific that they want to engage
china that they are developing trying to
develop a stable predictable
relationship with china and at the same
time engaging other countries in the
region
not just on strategic and security
issues but also on economic cooperation
and trade and
other investment and environmental and
sustainability links
so at a very broad level i think the
consensus is there at the level of
specific policies each
administration launches new initiatives
i'm quite convinced having seen several
administration that this one
is
completely focused
on achieving something lasting in asia
and we in singapore will do our best to
help to make sure that the proposals
work
and will take root and will continue to
grow for many years to come
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
you